Award for Best Direction ladies and
gentlemen Marlon Brando
or direction
in New York the winner is on the
waterfront Eli event
the director doesn't make a picture a
whole lot of people do and I thank each
one of them thank you thank you
how do you feel about Elijah's and
winning that Oscar huh
well I'm tickled to death Bob he looked
pretty nervous how do you feel I'm
tickled to death Bob you look pretty
nothing well I want to tell you it's a
great thrill having you on I think this
is your first Academy Award show yes it
is first time yeah you never could get
together on the money and I think it's
wonderful wonderful to have you here and
I especially thought you were great in
that picture on the waterfront everybody
in it got nominated except the pigeon
what happened to him well he turned out
to be well adjusted
who's his agent say I must say that your
success is well deserved after all
you're young
you're handsome you're vigorous and
you're talented and you're let me see
there was another reason why I hated you
well Bob I've been very lucky I've had
good directors and good stories and you
know why don't you do what I did you
know what I told you to do last year get
Tennessee Williams to write your next
movie
Tennessee Williams I got Tennessee Ernie
not to move in the right direction good
luck
oh that was quite a day when I posed for
that I want to tell you
you